طيب قبل
بالتاكيد كره قدم قبل انطلاق مباراه
فريقهم امام رايو فايكانو امس في الدوري
دخل لاعب ريال مدريد أرضى الملعب مرتديلا
قميصه زميلهم فينيسيوس جونيور تضامنا معه
بعد حادث العنصريه التي اثارت ضجه عالميه
وليست اسرائيل فينيسيوس قد اشتبك مشاهدينا
مع جمهور فالنسيا في الجوله الخامسه من
الدوري بعدما استهدفوه بالهتفات المسيئه
معظم اوقات المباراه وتسببت ايضا في ايقاف
اللقاء لنحو عشر دقائق الاتحاد الاسباني
اصدر بيانا فرض فيها غرامه ماليه قدرها 45
الف يورو على نادي فالنسيا واغلب اغلاق
جزئي لملعبه لخمس مباريات ولكن في الدقه
20 من
الذي يرتدي رقم عشرين الاضواء حتى وان ذهب
دوري ابطال اوروبا او الدوري الاسباني لكن
الاضواء لا تغيب عن ريال مدريد
في الموضوع هذا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات